daum ich an egal ob es dunkel oder hell
ist und ihr seht ein riesenschritt wie
bei psp die pelle und diesen track ein
richtig fetten nach zurückgeben werde
ich meinen plan schließt in eure
richtung 10
ja das bin ich euer zahnlücken toni alle
meine fans machen mich so ronny und nun
zu hoch denn die führt euch zerfetzt
jetzt wurde und scheiß auf den homo shop
die sagen
[Musik]
unsere klare nicht verstößt
ich habe den eindruck dass es ist deine
muss
[Musik]
stolz
gefahren
stolz sind die alle kein berg gibt dann
gibt es heute auch kein verbot das ist
der letzte sommer
ja
[Musik]
hi leute ich freue mich jetzt wieder
alle fragen wie ich das dann gemacht
habe erkläre ich es euch das ganze
antwort und zwar gibt es ja in fordert
jetzt diesen green screen und zwar in
rees carriers und in anderen städten und
bevor ich dorthin gekommen bin musste
ich erst mal mit meinen mittelmäßigen
fähigkeiten noch mittelmäßige report
einen spieler wegklatschen und dann kann
man auch schon in das haus gehen das ist
das größte haus in dieser stadt und da
sieht man diesen greenscreen vorher war
ich mir nicht dann meine viel zu teuren
und die zahlreichen wollen hat er uns
eingesetzt hat danach bin ich in dieses
wiederholungs programm von foreign hand
gegangen dass er seit neuem drin ist
weiß ich ziemlich geil finde haben wir
sagen eingestellt habe es ein bisschen
heller gemacht und hat es dann einfach
aufgenommen wird einem aufnahmeprogramm
ich habe dafür ubs benutzt das habe ich
dann in achterwehr angezogen habe den
green screen aus maskiert habe dann noch
mehr gruppe maske herumgezogen um die
ganzen ränder wegzuschneiden das passt
dann natürlich farblich nicht so rein
deswegen habe ich noch ein paar sachen
geändert wie zb kontrast farbgebung
allgemein bisschen die tiefen
runtergezogen wenn man das dann abspielt
stellen dann aber direkt fest dass diese
figur immer noch irgendwie komplett dumm
herum schwebt deswegen habe ich einen
punkt in diesem film material verfolgt
und zwar da hinten bei diesem
brandenburger tor diese direkte bewegung
habe ich dann auf diesen vorteil
gegenüber tragen habt ihr noch ein
bisschen rum positioniert damit der
größte ist und dann passt die bewegung
auch schon allerdings sieht man ja hier
direkt dass der arm des scans immer über
tanzverbots arm ist und ich wollte
eigentlich das so haben dass dieses kind
hinter tchibo steht deswegen habe ich
seinen arm noch aus maskiert und über
den skin gelegt und das war eigentlich
auch schon die ganze magie ich hoffe
dass wieder deutlich gefallen wenn ihr
lust auf mehr hat dann abonniert doch
main kanal und generell wenn ihr bock
habt mich auf diese gallen reise zu
begleiten dann abonniert doch diesen
kanal und dann sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal wieder
[Musik]